he was stripped guards team captain and
won a league championship with them
thomas hitzlsperger also played for
germany's national team 52 times during
his time in England he was called hits
the hammer for his thunderous shots on
goal hits oz burger waited until hanging
up his boots before coming out in an
interview with Germany's deed site
newspaper he said quote it's only been
in the last few years that I realized I
would rather live with a man in an
earlier interview hit CIL's burger had
said coming out wasn't a good idea for
players since it would spell the end of
their careers but now he says he wants
to advance the discussion of
homosexuality in football his
announcement earned praise from sporting
and political circles what does over it
was it's good that he's talking about
something that's important to him and
that may be liberating we live in a
country where no one should be afraid to
acknowledge their sexuality because of
fear of intolerance huntsville
intolerance it's aight of he encouraged
and for that he deserves recognition he
also knows that if he needs support he
can come to us in the German Football
Federation does is he but once in DF
beba convert Germany team manager Oliver
Bierhoff also said hit CIL's pegar
deserved respect and on Twitter national
player lukas podolski congratulated him
for his courage